returning home is becoming an elusive
dream for these refugees
they've been living in tents for nearly
a decade here in the city of the hook in
iraq's kurdish region
we have been displaced for eight years
the situation in sinjar is getting worse
how can we think of going back to sinjar
security and safety are two important
elements for us and because of the lack
of these two elements we prefer to stay
in the camp and enjoy its harsh
conditions our hearts are broken for not
being able to go back
most of the nearly three hundred
thousand people here are from the yazidi
minority
they were forced to flee their homes
about ten years ago nearly half of them
live in these tent camps that barely
protect them from the summer heat and
the winter cold the governments in
baghdad and erbil signed an agreement in
2020 for all irregular forces to
withdraw from sinjar to allow the safe
return of those displaced by war
but that agreement is yet to be
implemented
the terms of the sinjar agreement were
not implemented despite the consent of
both governments it seems there are
pressures on the iraqi government to
block the agreement from foreign powers
that support the militia's
non-withdrawal from sinjar
the iraqi government says it's committed
to the agreement and its forces are in
control of sinjar but people here say
armed militias including the kurdistan
workers party or pkk have never left
we as joint operations command did
everything we had to do in terms of
security we are serious about
implementing this agreement but there
are certain things that the government
has to do from our side we will not
allow any manifestation of armed
activities inside sinjar
sinjar is officially run by a joint
administration based in the hook some of
its members are appointed by the iraqi
government in baghdad while others are
locally elected
but the reported presence of armed
groups is making it complicated and
difficult to facilitate the return of
refugees muhammad